Ich bin übrigens kaputt, ich wusste gar nicht ob ich Stream anmachen soll, aber ich
habe mir gedacht, was will sie großartig machen, was gibt es besseres als eine Runde
Streamen.
Aber wie gesagt, Sonderliche 5-Header-Time wird es heute nicht werden, weil ich kann
mich jetzt nicht wirklich großartig konzentrieren, hier 5, 6, 11-Head-Dinger machen.
Ich muss zwar wieder nach Frankfurt fahren, unsinnigerweise, außer dass ich da irgendwie
wieder mehr oder weniger dreiviertel des Tages gemietet habe, ist eigentlich sehr überflüssig
gewesen.
Am Rande, ich habe ein paar Videos geguckt, aber es juckt mich wenig, das juckt mich
genauso viel wie diese, ich weiß gar nicht wie der Typ heißt, Flynn oder so, der Typ
mit den Masken, der irgendwie die Masken verkauft hat und dann sich für gefeiert hat, als
hätte er sie gespendet und es irgendwelche komischen China-Chinesen-Masken waren.
Keine Ahnung, ich kriege das alles so am Rande mit, aber es geht mir alles vorbei,
wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Juckt mich alles nicht, was ich heißt, dass ich irgendwas gut finde, das juckt mich einfach
nicht.
Oder schlecht, das juckt mich einfach nicht.
Wie gesagt, ich weiß auch nicht mal wie der Kerl heißt, irgendwie gefühlt wahrscheinlich
90% in Deutschland wissen das nicht, ich hab keine Ahnung.
Flynn oder so, wie heißt denn der Dude, sagt mal, ihr wisst das doch, Chet, Kiemann Flynn
oder irgendwie so, Klee, Klee, nee, Cleansman war jemand anderes, ach keine Ahnung, wie
gesagt, das interessiert mich auch überhaupt nicht, Leute, ich weiß nicht mal wie der
Typ heißt.
Ich muss mal kurz in meine Mails gucken, ach Finn, ach ja, ja, irgendwas mit Finn wusste
ich doch.
Kann man das auch nur merken, weil der Meshed Finn heißt, der Einzige den ich kenne, der
Finn heißt...
Moment, ich hab mein E-Mail-Passwort falsch eingegeben, warum mache ich denn sowas?
So, kurz E-Mails check, Swann, Pay Reminder, warum das, oh, darfst du keinem erzählen,
ich hab meine Hetzner-Rechnung nicht bezahlt diesen Monat bis jetzt, die hab ich grad
ein Reminder geschickt, für 5,83 Euro, Alter, was hab ich denn da überhaupt, was 5,83 Euro
kostet noch?
Irgendeine Single-VM, oder, 5,83 Euro, Mann, das sieht sehr nach Single-VM aus, oder?
Das steht doch auf der Rechnung bestimmt drauf, ne.
Du hast Twitch, bestimmt, bestimmt, hast du Twitch gehackt, daran wird es liegen, dass
man die Nachrichten nicht sieht.
Geh ich auch von aus, es kann, es kann keinen anderen Grund geben, als, als hast du, dass
du Twitch gehackt hast, ja, so ist es, Horst-Champ, wie siehts heute aus, Weeps in oder Weeps
out?
Ich bin ja immer für Weeps in, wow, Alter, viel zu laut, Mann, MonkaS, Sekunde, Sekunde,
Freund, geht es hier drüber, muss mal kurz den Aja-Ja-Sound runterschrauben, so, das
ist jetzt doch noch laut genug, ja, ok, ok, das kann man so ertragen, mal testen, was
sagt der, was sagt der Wendler dazu?
Ok, Sound passt, alles klar, macht der eigentlich, ist das immer noch in seiner Telegram-Gruppe?
Was für ein Ding, seit ich wieder festbar eine Mix aus Uberspace, ist das irgendein
Co-Location-Host, sagt mir gar nichts, und selbst Hosted bin, habe ich meinen Hetzer-Server
wieder weg, aber eigentlich ganz zufrieden mit den, ja, die sind nicht schlecht, ich
hab dieses Jahr, haben wir noch nichts ausgehandelt, das heißt, mein Hetzer-Startgutscheincode
funktioniert auch nicht mehr, obwohl man den gerade jetzt, wo die Leute eh schon wieder
wenig Kohle haben, brauchen könnte.
Ja, Leute, also, grüne Pizza, Dankeschön für den Sub, Massive zwei Monate.
Zeig mal, zeig mal her, was für ein Ding, Uberspace, Hosting of Asteroids, ok, ich bin
froh, dass die nicht schreiben, Hosting on Steroids, das ist so, das ist so eine Redewendung,
die kann ich überhaupt nicht leiden, das war, das war mal eine Zeitlein sehr angesagt, so
zu der Zeit, wo auch Hubi-Entwickler sich als Rockstar-Developer bezeichnet haben, da
war alles blablabla on Steroids und, ok, und was können die so geiles, dass die, dass,
dass man Universal-Hosting für Shell-Lovers, aha, kurz ein bisschen leiser machen, Leute,
ich muss mir zu laut gerade, mach das mal wieder hoch, ich hab ja auch viel zu laut,
fällt mir gerade auf, normalerweise hab ich immer auf 30, Leute, ich muss die Resident-Sleeper,
ich muss die kurz ein bisschen durch was, etwas, etwas weniger, äh, Resident-Sleeper-Riches
ersetzen, weil ansonsten ist gleich wirklich Badge angesagt, das fände ich tatsächlich
geil, wenn einer ein Rechenzentrum auf dem Mond eröffnet, wisst ihr warum ich das geil
finde, weniger wegen dem Rechenzentrum auf dem Mond, ich seh nämlich ehrlich gesagt
nicht so wirklich, wo der Sinn von einem Rechenzentrum auf dem Mond ist, also was es für Vorteile
haben soll, außer, äh, Strahlung, ähm, beschissene Latenz, ähm, wo kriegt's den Strom, also
eigentlich nur Probleme, aber warum ich's geil finden würde ist, weil dann müsste jemand
mal wieder auf den Mond fliegen, dort landen und da was Sinnvolles machen, da wart ich
ja drauf, die Amis haben das ja vor ein paar Jahren angekündigt, dass sie wieder auf den
Mond fliegen wollen, aber mittlerweile, hat sich da nicht viel getan, ah ja, ich wollt
ja gucken, was die so Geiles haben, also, was, Pricing, zeig her, äh, Rakete, das ist ein
gutes Pricing, Budget, 5 Euro, ja, und was bekommt man da, ich, ich sag, ich versteh's
nicht, also ich mein, mal angenommen, ich bezahl da jetzt 15 Euro, was bekomm ich dafür,
so genau, ich, ich, so, ich versteh's nicht so, so richtig, man bekommt da einen Container
oder was, einen Container und auf dem kann man machen, was man will, ja, aber, was hält
mich da von ab, in, habe, ja gut, ich hab wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Limits oder so,
wahrscheinlich ist es keine VM, ok, das muss ich mal angucken, Chat, ich hab's nicht so
genau kapiert, ehrlich gesagt, der ideale Ort, Rechenzentrum, der Mond ist doch alles
andere als der ideale Ort für ein Rechenzentrum, also manche, ich mein, muss man denn sagen,
also manche Unternehmen haben sehr gutes Marketingmaterial und können viel Zeug erzählen, aber mir kann
niemand erzählen, dass der optimale Standort für ein Rechenzentrum auf dem Mond ist, und
ok, warum, warum ist das so, Sub ignoriert, Doom Swap, danke für den Sub, Kengin, Pogger,
Sub, ich seh's jetzt zwar nicht, aber Dankeschön, nice, ach hier 17 Monate, Massive, Pfeifheader,
Sub, ok, jetzt lassen wir uns doch mal kurz erklären, du hast für drei Monate gesubbt,
das ist ja, dazu kann ich nur sagen, oder alternativ, oder alternativ, wenn man auf
die Ollen Call of Duty Sachen steht, Weirdchamp, danke für den Sub, ok, also, was haben wir
denn hier, um Daten und Rechenkapazität, wie macht man das eigentlich gescheit, mit Kühlung
auf dem Mond, egal, um Daten und Rechenkapazität auch in notwendigen, ok, krisensicher auf
dem Mond, also ganz ehrlich, wenn hier die Welt untergeht, auf der Erde, ich weiß nicht,
ob uns das Rechenzentrum auf dem Mond rettet, aber das ist tatsächlich ein Punkt, den lasse
ich mir noch irgendwie gefallen, ja, weil mein Content so gut ist, das ist schön, dass
dir mein Content gefällt, ok, das unternehmen hat sich dafür auch am, im kommenden Jahr,
ja Moment, in diesem Jahr, das sagen die ganzen Startups, und dann passiert fünf Jahre nichts
und sie gehen out of Service, ein bisschen teurer, ok, ja, was jetzt der Vorteil davon
ist, hat man immer noch, nicht so genau verstanden, also es gibt ein großes Problem, wenn die
Erde unbewohnbar wird, dann sind wahrscheinlich die Leute dort dann irgendwann tot, und tote
Leute interessieren sich wenig für Daten im Rechenzentrum auf dem Mond, aber ok, ich
bin, hey, vielleicht gibt es ja da irgendeinen Markt für, keine Ahnung, aktuell sieht das
für mich einfach nur nach irgendwie, Schnapsidee, Startups Schnapsidee aus, aber ok, wenn sie
meinen, breche ich jetzt auf dem Mond, ach so soll das aussehen, ja gut, das können die
ganzen Ami Startups auch immer gut, irgendwelche Renderbilder machen, mit wie das mal in Zukunft
aussehen wird, wie sie, Dankeschön für den Zap, aber, also mir erschließt sich die Logik
nicht, was man mit dem Rechenzentrum auf dem Mond macht, also was der Sinn davon ist, weil
das ist quasi der unsinnigste Platz für den Rechenzentrum, der mir so einfällt, ansonsten
keine Ahnung, ja ich lasse das Argument irgendwie zum Teil ziehen, dass sie sagen, ja da sind
die Daten sicher vor irgendwelchen Katastrophen auf der Erde, wobei man halt sagen muss, wenn
man so große globale Katastrophen auf der Erde hat, dass jetzt auch ein, mehrfach redundantausgelegter
Daten auf der Erde weg sind, ja, also sprich, wenn man seine Daten spiegelt, sagen wir mal,
einmal in Europa, einmal in Nordamerika und einmal in Asien oder so zum Beispiel, und
alle drei Standorte sind wirklich kaputt, dann muss ja irgendwas hier von wirklich großem
Ausmaß passiert sein, also da langt es weder, dass die Russen in der Ukraine sind, noch
dass Kim Jong-Dings irgendwie komische Dinge macht oder was weiß ich, dass irgendwelche
Alawakbar-Leute am Start sind, da muss ja wirklich was globales passieren, weltweit, wenn du
einen geo-redundanten Datentopf kaputt kriegst, also was ist der Vorteil von einem Rechenzentrum
auf dem Mond, ich weiß es nicht, keine Ahnung, was auch immer, ich muss aber nicht jede Startup-Idee
verstehen, weil wenn es danach geht, ich würde wahrscheinlich nie ein Startup gründen und
ich würde wahrscheinlich auch die, die funktionieren, nie gründen, das heißt, ich bin da schlechter
Ratgeber wahrscheinlich, weil ich alles schlecht finde, von Startup-Ideen gehe ich mal von aus,
das meiste will ich schlecht finden, aber in dem Fall verstehe ich es wirklich nicht,
wo das Sinn ist, was ist es, es ist das Gegenteil von On-Prem, das ist ja dann auch nicht in
der Cloud, da braucht man dann noch ein drittes Wort für oder, also ich meine, wir haben Cloud, wir
haben Lokal, also coole Leute nennen das On-Prem, aber ich nenne es mal Lokal, so wie normale Leute
das nennen, was ist denn das, Overcloud, Intergalactic, nee, Space, aber Space ist tatsächlich ein
bisschen zu, zu normales Wort für super agiles Startup-Dinger, Orbit, Orbit finde ich gut,
Hyperspace, so Galactic, Galactic Cloud oder so, Superlativ brauchst du da schon ein bisschen,
Marco, was sagt denn das heise Forum dazu? Ideal für, wie macht man das, blöde Frage,
habt ihr eine Vorstellung, habt ihr, oder habt ihr eine klorische Idee, wie man das dort gescheit
mit der Kühlung macht, weil ich mein, ja, wenn nicht gerade die Sonne drauf scheint, ist es kalt,
aber du musst ja Server, also du musst ja die Kälte irgendwie an die Server bekommen und das
Problem ist am Vakuum, dass selbst wenn du sagen wir mal einen großen passiven Kühlklotz nimmst
und den raushängst, du hast ja wenig, wenig, du hast ja kein Material, du hast ja keine Luft drum
oder kein Wasser drum oder sonst was, was quasi die Wärme da leiten würde, also ich bin mir
nicht so sicher, ob man das Zeug gescheit kühlen kann, ja Strahlung, da gibt es so viele Probleme,
die habe ich ja gerade schon ein paar aufgezählt, Strahlung, Strahlung ist wahrscheinlich noch das
kleinste, die Latenz zur Erde ist eigentlich das, was mir am meisten Sorgen macht, da sieht
der Satelliten nix dagegen, ich weiß nicht, was ist, was ist Lichtgeschwindigkeit zum Mond,
wie lange, wie lange braucht man da, sein Licht rein, okay, überlegt euch das mal, im aller, aller,
allerbesten Fall braucht ein Ping 2,5, 2,5, 2,5 Sekunden, im aller, allerbesten Fall, realistisch
betrachtet wird es noch eine ganze, eine ganze Weile mehr dauern, weil du musst ja erstmal gucken,
dass du auch dann im richtigen, du kommst, es reicht ja wahrscheinlich nicht, wenn du irgendwo
auf der Erde runter kommst, du musst ja wahrscheinlich noch halbwegs, du musst das Signal wahrscheinlich
noch relayen mit irgendwelchen Satelliten, weil ansonsten musst du es nochmal quer durch die
ganze Erde schicken, je nachdem, wo das gerade empfangen wird, die Bandbreite wird wahrscheinlich
nicht so berauschend sein, das ist ja quasi wie Satelliteninternet nur noch, noch, noch viel,
viel, viel, viel, viel langsamer, 2.560 Millisekunden Ping, ja, das ist doch nix,
das ist doch Intergalactic Data Center, also ich weiß nicht, die Start-up Idee überzeugt mich jetzt
persönlich nicht so wirklich, aber wer weiß, vielleicht wird es der neue große Shit, dann
kann er das Elon Musk irgendwann kaufen, wenn das, der hat irgendwie eh zu viel Geld, was das angeht, und dann kann er
selbst Server hochschicken, ich meine, hat er nicht schon irgendeinen Tesla in die Umlaufbahn geschossen,
dann wäre doch jetzt das nächste ein Tesla auf den Mond, beziehungsweise ein paar Server auf,
auf den Mond wenigstens. Okay, also wie funktioniert das, die machen viel über Querfinanzierung,
du bekommst einen Nutzer, also geht es übrigens nicht um das Rechenzentrum auf dem Mond, sondern
um diesen Hosting-Anbieter, du bekommst einen Nutzer in einer 4MD-Limit, sind halt sehr, sehr locker,
zumindest meiner Meinung nach bekommt man gerade für Spitzen mehr das, als bei anderen für die
Produktion. Das heißt, ich könnte da auch mal kurz mal, also könnte ich da beispielsweise auch mein
Open Street View preprocessen, das braucht 48 CPU-Kerner, damit es ungefähr so in 40 Minuten
fertig ist. Und, und ich glaube 40 oder 50 Gigabyte RAM, oder, oder löschen die mich dann direkt,
dafür brauche ich da aber auch nur 40 Minuten für dann. Mal kurz ja, kurz sind da wahrscheinlich
keine 40 Minuten, 48 Kerne und 50 Gigabyte RAM, oder? Das ist wahrscheinlich nicht, nicht, nicht,
nicht kurz. Das haben ja schon viele gemacht, wobei ganz ehrlich, das ist im Kryptosektor,
glaube ich, deutlich attraktiver. Nur, dass da die Investoren irgendwelche privaten Leute sind,
die du verarschst, in denen sagst, gibts uns euer Geld. Was ich persönlich immer sehr beeindruckend
finde, dass das überhaupt funktioniert. Generell sollte man auch mittlerweile im Internet ja
eigentlich gecheckt haben, dass Leute, die sagen, gib mir dein Geld und ich mach dich reich, egal ob
das in irgendwelche Gruppen sind, wo du reingehen sollst, oder Leute, die dich mit Krypto reich
machen. Kurz eben mal gucken, was meine Stonks machen. Meine Stonks sind heute, dass das alles
Scam ist. Oh, 85 Euro, meine Stonks, immerhin. 85 Euro, 542 Euro die Woche. Na, da kann ich
doch mit leben. Besser als weiter, minus, Alter. Aber immer noch im Minus, also ich hab immer noch
keinen Plus gemacht mit meinen Stonks. Na ja. Und Amazon ist auch nicht besser. Na ja, was auch immer.
Entspannter RZ-Kontrollgang auf dem Boot, ja. Okay, das ist wohl wahr. Man braucht dort keinen
Sicherheitsdienst oder so. Da kommt halt, da kommt jetzt nicht mal so nebenbei einer hin.
Äh, ist die Erde nicht immer noch näher an Satelliten als der Mond? Satelliten sind irgendwie
so 80.000 Kilometer teilweise weg. Also nicht die Tiefen, sondern die höheren, oder? Sind
die irgendwie 80.000 Kilometer weg oder sowas? Und da ist der Mond ja deutlich weiter weg als,
ja, aber vielleicht, ja. Jo, danke für den Sub. Was machen eigentlich die Microsoft Unterwasser
Rechenzentren? Was machen die so? Die gibt's anscheinend noch, okay. Ah nee, die sind doch
nicht so geil. Ach, weniger Fehler anfällig. Ja, die haben da irgendwie so ein U-Boot versenkt,
weil das ist im Gegensatz zum Mond tatsächlich eine relativ gute Idee für Kühlung. Weil da hast
du quasi Wasserkühlung gratis. Oh, kurz bin ich ein bisschen schneller. Ja, genau, das werden
die machen. Die umgehen einfach mal, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, wie es heißt, die umgeben
einfach mal das Problem, dass du halt auch mit Quantenverschränkungen und Geschichten
keine Informationen gescheit übertragen kannst. Aber da werden die schon was Neues, also was
du gar nicht gescheit gar nicht übertragen kannst, das werden die schon, die werden das lösen. Easy,
kein Problem. Also ich habe ja Vertrauen in Startups generell, die sagen immer nur die Wahrheit,
die sagen immer nur, wie es ist. Genauso, der beste, eines der geilsten Startup Scams war doch
diese Geschichte mit, die stechen dir in den Finger und können dann irgendwie 5000 Krankheiten
erkennen, was nie richtig funktioniert hat, wo da kerngesunde Leute krebsdiagnostiziert
wurde und sowas. Ich habe vergessen, wie die hießen, aber das war auch richtig massive
Scam. Mit dieser plonten Vorstandsfrau da von denen. War noch jemand im Kopf, wie die heißen?
Was mit T? Was mit T? Terra? TerraBus oder so? Wie hießen die denn? Moment, Startup, Scam, der
schon mit Elisabeth kommt. Ja, die meine ich doch, die meine ich doch. TerraNos, nicht TerraBus.
Wie komme ich auf TerraBus? TerraBus gibt es das überhaupt? Okay, das ist tatsächlich ein Bus,
alles klar. Ich war aber nah dran, TerraBus war das. Ja, die meine ich. Weiß ich, ob die jetzt im
Knast gelandet ist? Also das war auch so richtig, richtig massive Scam. Da gab es dann irgendwelche
Wellness und Hotelketten, die den Kram gekauft haben und am Ende haben die Sachen diagnostiziert
bei Leuten, was sie nie hatten. Nee, nee, die meine ich nicht. Ich meinte hier diese Elisabeth
Homes. Ja, den gibt es auch. Weiß ich gar nicht. Das ist so ein lila Ding gewesen, oder? Ich habe
Brick und Morty nie großartig geguckt, aber den Plumbus oder wie man das ausführt, den kenne
ich auch. Das ist auch so eine Serie, wo ich total oft gelesen habe, dass man das eigentlich nicht
weiter als, glaube ich, zweite Staffel oder so gucken muss, weil ihnen dann irgendwie die Ideen
ausgegangen sind. Ich weiß nicht, ob das stimmt. Habe ich gelesen, keine Ahnung. Nie groß geguckt.
So Leute, also ich sage euch mal, was wir heute vorhaben. Ich habe nichts großartig vor. Ich
bin mega im Arsch, weil ich heute mal wieder sinnloserweise nach Frankfurt fahren musste,
dementsprechend früher aufstehen und hin und zurück. Und mir sind die Leute heute im Zug
schon wieder richtig auf den Sack gegangen. Es ist unglaublich, wie die das schaffen. In den Zug
eingestiegen und morgen gegenüber, also stimmt nicht, also eine Sitzreihe vor mir,
eine gehabt, die am Telefon rumschreit, weil sie daheim irgendwas gesucht haben und nicht gefunden.
Also laut gesprochen, nicht wirklich ist es törig rumgeschrien, sondern laut gesprochen.
Alter, haltet doch einer mal die Klappe. Und dann war es auch noch so voll wieder. Dann hatte
ich eine Kontrollfrau, die nicht wusste, wie man oder es nicht auf die Reihe gekriegt hat,
meine Karte zu kontrollieren im, wie nennt man das, Kartenschutzbehälter. Ich habe so
elektronisches Ticket und das hat irgendwie nicht funktioniert. Und da muss ich das rausfummeln.
Dabei habe ich meine Eintrittskarte und meine Fahrkarte und das Geld alles in so einem
Schutzbehälter reingestopft, dass ich eben alles zusammen in der Tasche habe. Die Leute gehen mir
einfach drauf. Ich soll mich einfach in Ruhe lassen. Tja, dafür, dafür, warte mal auf das
9 Euro Ticket. Ganz ehrlich, ich finde die Idee von dem 9 Euro Ticket nicht schlecht. Gerade,
also aus mehreren Gründen, aus mehreren Gründen. Und ob das mit mit Sylt so krass wird,
wie die Leute denken, da habe ich eh so meine Zweifel, aber warten wir mal ab, warten wir mal
ab. Ich finde, ich finde das 9 Euro Ticket aus mehreren Gründen gut. Erstens finde ich,
dass das prinzipiell eine gute Idee ist, wenn man den Leuten sagen möchte, sie sollen nicht mit dem
Auto in die Stadt fahren und das teilweise sogar schon denkt, dass per Gesetzverordnung auch immer
die Leute vorzuschreiben, nicht mehr mit dem Auto in die Stadt zu fahren, dann muss man ja
irgendwie Alternativen schaffen. Zum Glück hat sich das dann nicht durchgesetzt mit dem
Verbieten, das wäre auch absolut nicht praktikabel gewesen, aber das könnte ja zumindest ein erster
Schritt sein, wenn man das irgendwie dann beibehält, wo bestimmt einige Leute sagen würden, hey,
das ist so viel günstiger als Auto fahren, das würde ich machen. So, ganz kostenlos, weiß ich
nicht, ob es eine gute Idee ist, weil dann hast du auch quasi die ganzen Assis den ganzen Tag nur noch
in der Bahn abgammeln, das wird vielleicht bei dem 9 Euro Ticket schon ein bisschen so sein,
aber ich glaube, bei 9 Euro, da ist es so, die ganz Ultra Assis, die überlegen sich dann auch
nochmal bei 9 Euro. Naja, zumindest der zweite Grund, warum ich es gut finde, dass noch mehr
Leute mal auf den Boden der Tatsache geholt werden, den Satz muss ich neu anfangen,
dass noch ein paar mehr Leute damit jetzt quasi in Kontakt kommen mit der Bahn und auf den Boden
der Tatsachen geholt werden, was für ein absoluter Picker-Drecks-Verein die Bahn ist. Und ich rede
nicht von irgendwie dem Einzelnen, der sich täglich den Arsch aufreißt, dass es doch noch funktioniert,
sondern ich meine das Gesamtkonzept, also das Gesamtkonstrukt. Das ist der allerletzte Scheißhaufen,
die Bahn und ich hoffe, dass dadurch noch mehr Leute das mitbekommen und sich vielleicht mal
irgendwas tut, außer schön gerechnete Statistiken. Also das sind so die Gründe, warum ich das
eigentlich ganz gut finde. Nur die Leute, wo ich es nicht gut finde, ist, die darunter leiden müssen,
die eventuell dann im Berufsverkehr quasi gar nicht mehr durchkommen und eventuell dann Auto
fahren, weil sie wirklich, müssen wir mal gucken, da bin ich gespannt, da bin ich gespannt. Ich habe
ja schon, ich habe ja schon die ersten Kommentare gelesen, die gesagt haben, man sollte es im
Berufsverkehr verbieten. Dann kamen die nächsten Leute an, die gesagt haben, ja, man sollte verbieten,
dass die Leute, die ein 9-Euro-Ticket haben, noch überhaupt fahren mit dem Auto. Und wisst ihr,
was ich mir bei solchen Kommentaren immer denke? Wie wär's dann einfach mit gar nichts verbieten?
Muss man jeden Scheiß verbieten, immer wenn einem nichts besseres einfällt als Alternative. Gibt
es auch so viel Anreize, die man setzen kann, Sachen, wie man, wie man Dinge beeinflussen kann,
ohne gleich zu sagen, nee, alles oder nichts. Naja. Ich bin mal gespannt, was da dran wird.
Ehrlich gesagt habe ich keine Ahnung, aber auf jeden Fall ein ganz, ganz großer Teil. Aber es
müssen eigentlich 100% Anteile der Bahn gehören, weil die Bahn ist ja nie so wirklich öffentlich an
die Börse und konnte da gehandelt werden. Das heißt jetzt zwar nicht zwangsläufig, dass alles 100%
ich dem, ich weiß es nicht, keine Ahnung. Naja, aber dann wird Geld wenigstens mal für was
verbrannt, wo man was von hat. Ja, gut, das kannst du bei allem sagen. Wenn es danach geht, darfst du
dir auch kein Elektroauto kaufen, weil nichts ist umweltschonender, als ein altes Schrottauto noch
weiter zu fahren, bis es letztendlich auseinanderfällt. Aber ja, ich, ich, also wie sagt man,
ich gette den Point, ja, da ist natürlich schon was dran. Scheiß Satz, Alter. Gettet ihr auch
manchmal den Point, Leute? Pains Jam. Ich bin mal gespannt, was da rauskommt. Ich bin ja auch mal
gespannt, ob das überhaupt, ist das eigentlich mittlerweile alles genehmigt und geregelt und so.
Ich bin ja auch mal gespannt. Nee, ist ja nicht durch. Ob sie das wirklich schaffen, bis, man soll
es ja angeblich irgendwie ab 5. Mai oder so, 25. Mai kaufen können. Ich bin mal wirklich gespannt,
ob das überhaupt möglich ist. Also wisst ihr, wie ich meine, ich bin mal gespannt,
ob sie das überhaupt hinbekommen, das zu genehmigen. Ich, ich, ich hab da nicht so,
wie soll ich sagen, ich hab da nicht so hohes Vertrauen, weil ihr erinnert euch vielleicht
noch, okay, das ist jetzt ein bisschen was anderes, aber es ist immer das beste Beispiel,
was mir dafür einfällt. Ihr erinnert euch doch vielleicht noch daran, dass wir abgestimmt haben,
wie es mit Sommer-Winterzeit-Umstellung aussieht. Da ist auch nicht so viel passiert,
obwohl alle gesagt haben, so ein Scheiß weg damit. Moin, WoutsTronic. Tommy schreibt,
wollt ihr mal live danke sagen, ich schaue seit 2014 deine Videos und hab dir, hab dank dir mein
Interesse zu IT geworden. Das finde ich immer schön, wenn das Leute schreiben. Du bist nicht
der Erste, der da schreibt. Das finde ich aber immer cool. Ich muss dazu sagen, mittlerweile mache
ich ja auch Videos manchmal mit dem Hinblick drauf, weil ich jetzt weiß, dass Leute sich den Graben
angucken, die vielleicht in Zukunft in diese Richtung gehen werden oder gehen wollen, ja.
Damals habe ich Videos, ehrlich gesagt, auch wenn es sich so angehört hat, weniger mit dem
Hintergedanken gemacht, weil es mir gar nicht klar war, dass es, weil ich es wirklich realisiert
habe, dass das tatsächlich Leute beeinflusst oder man könnte ja sagen, quasi influenced,
wie das heutzutage heißt, dass da was zu machen. Aber ich finde, ich finde, ich finde das immer
schön zu lesen, ja. So, also heute mit 21 Jahren arbeite ich. Okay, wenn du heute 21 bist, warst du
damals eines der ganzen 12-jährigen Call of Duty Kinder, die rumgeflapt haben unter den Channels,
gib es zu, unter den Videos. Da gibt es ganz viele. Chat, wer von euch war da auch dabei?
Ganz viele, ich weiß es auch von vielen Kommentaren. Genau so einer war ich, ja, war klar.
Heute mit 21 Jahren arbeite ich bei einem großen Automobilkonzern in der Entwicklung und mache
viel Geld nebenher als Freelancer mit anderen Projekten. Dadurch, durch die habe ich sehr früh
selber Programmieren beigebracht, mich viel weiter gemeldet in Sachen harten Software, ich war ständig
von meinem Vorgesetzten gelobt. Na dann, siehst du man, besser, besser konnte es doch gar nicht
laufen. Du musst nur gucken, es fällt mir gerade an der Stelle ein, ich weiß ja nicht, was, was da
jetzt genau dahinter steckt. Du musst nur gucken, dass sie dich ordentlich bezahlen und nicht ausbeuten.
Das ist auch was, das habe ich erst später kapiert, da habe ich früher auch nichts so gesagt in Videos,
weil es gibt manche Leute, gerade im Management, die haben da Talente für, sie haben ein gewisses
Gespür dafür, was Leute hören wollen und erzählen das dann den Leuten und die geben sich damit zu
Frieden und fragen nicht nach mehr Geld. Aber wenn du sagst, du verdienst viel Kohle, dann ist ja
alles in Ordnung. Aber man sieht es bei unseren Pflegekräften und den Leuten im Supermarkt,
hast du nicht gesehen, rein mit warmen Worten bezahlt sich halt auch nichts. Wer ist der
FyFat-Content auf YouTube? Ja, so sieht es aus, aber es gibt noch mehr FyFat-Channels.
Aber es ist schön, dass das funktioniert hat. Ja, übrigens, achso, also wer darauf hofft,
dass wir heute irgendwas weiter programmieren oder basteln oder so, ich bin viel zu sehr im Arsch,
ich kann heute nichts großartig machen. Neues Armor schon gesehen? Nee. Ja, dann ist doch alles gut.
Naja, das kommt natürlich ganz entscheidend darauf an, ob sich dein Aufgabenfeld erweitert hat,
ob du jetzt andere Sachen machst, ob sich vielleicht grundsätzlich was geändert hat,
ob du jetzt andere Positionen hast oder sonst was. Das kann man so pauschal schlecht sagen.
Das kommt auf sehr vieles an. Ich tue mir da selbst auch immer schwer, mir was zu überlegen,
was ich sagen könnte. Aber eine Sache hat sich mittlerweile, das habe ich auch glaube ich in
dem Video mal erzählt, also eine Sache hat sich bei mir da, wie soll ich sagen, als lohnend
rausgestellt oder als sinnvoll rausgestellt immer mehr sagen als das, mit dem du zufrieden bist
oder als das, was du haben willst oder. Ja, also was weiß ich? Was weiß ich? Sagen wir sagen,
du verdienst 2000 Euro im Monat und du würdest gerne 2200 Euro im Monat verdienen und das ist
halt auch das, was du anstrebst. Dann kannst du nicht sagen, du möchtest 200 Euro mehr oder 10
Prozent mehr, was bei manche denken, das ist super viel. Also gerade bei uns machen sie auch,
wenn du bei einem zweistelligen Betrag ankommst, machen sie immer, machen sie Augen, ne, mach
Auge oder wie sagt man da mittlerweile? Sie machen Auge, wenn du da mit was zweistelligem ankommst.
Aber ganz im Ernst, sag ruhig das Doppelte von dem, was du haben willst. Das wirst du wahrscheinlich
nicht kriegen, aber dann kommt am Ende irgendwas anderes bei rum, wo du wahrscheinlich eher mit
zufrieden bist, als wenn du mit kleineren Sachen ins Rennen gehst. Und selbst wenn sich am Anfang
aus deinem Bauchgefühl unverschämt anhört, so viel zu sagen, es kann dir nichts passieren. Die
werden dich wegen einer etwas überhöhten Gehaltsvorstellung sicherlich nicht rausschmeißen.
Im Zweifelsfall lacht man dann mal drüber und dein Chef sagt, er guckt mal, was er für dich tun kann
oder was auch immer. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall besser, als zu niedrig anzufangen oder glatt mit
dem, mit dem du zufrieden bist. Weil natürlich, das verspricht dir am Ende nicht, dass das dann
auch wirklich genau das wird, was du haben willst. Aber das hat sich bei mir ganz gut bewährt.
Reforger. Das heißt nicht wirklich Reforger, oder? Der Name ist etwas verbrannt seit Warcraft.
Ich meine, das heißt, das hieß Reforged und das heißt Reforger, aber die Benamung ist schon
Pains Champ. Das läuft wahrscheinlich nur auf dem absoluten NASA PC. Arma läuft nie gut und jetzt
ist eh vorbei. Noch, noch, noch einen neuen. Warum sind die Leute nicht zufrieden? Simplified.
Moment, Moment. Die können Arma nicht simplifien. Wenn die Arma simplifien hat Arma keine
Daseinsberechtigung mehr. Jetzt ohne Scheiß. Das ist der Selling Point für Arma, dass es noch
mehr oder weniger Simulation ist. Das sind ja, glaube ich, die gleichen Leute, die früher auch
Operation Flashpoint und sowas gemacht haben. Bin mir nicht ganz sicher, aber ich glaube schon. Und
ich glaube, die haben auch tatsächlich für Militärs auf der Welt und sowas Simulation und
Sachen schon entwickelt. Also, die haben Plan. Und was ist die Daseinsberechtigung von Arma,
wenn Arma mit dem Controller easy spielbar und vercasualt ist? Also, Patrick ist, ich bin kaputt
als fuck, das geht. Immer gespannt. Ich bin kein großer Arma-Spieler. Kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Da kennt sich der Patrick mit aus. Was ich gemacht habe, ich musste sinnvollerweise unsinnigerweise
heute nach Frankfurt fahren für einen ganzen Tag voller Gemiete, die ich dann doch bis auf
eines über Teams gemacht habe. Alles klar. Muss man Arma mit Semper-Video spielen? Also,
ich kenne erstens Semper-Video nicht persönlich und zweitens kann ich Arma nicht. Ich glaube,
okay, ich lehne mich jetzt mal aus dem Fenster. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie gut der Sprecher in
Games ist, aber wahrscheinlich wird er jetzt auch nicht der überkrasse Arma-Basher sein.
Das hat sich richtig gelohnt, nach Frankfurt zu fahren dafür heute. Ihr müsst ja eure
neue Placing-Machine da hinbekommen. On-Prem-Video-Konferenz. Ja, habe ich heute quasi gemacht. Ich habe
den ganzen Tag gemietet. Über Teams vor Ort. Richtig bescheuert. Wie viele Leute seid ihr
denn mittlerweile? Wobei ihr braucht das wahrscheinlich hauptsächlich für irgendwelche Maschinen und
Sachen, die da rumstehen. Gehe ich mal von aus. Aber Leute, wenn ihr einen fragen wollt,
der sich mit Verhandlungen auskennt, fragt den Patrick. Der sagt einfach, bezahlt jetzt
mal ordentlich oder ich hau ab. Oder fickt euch, macht was ihr wollt und dann sagen die
alle, ja, wir bezahlen jetzt ordentlich. Ganz einfach, easy, so musst du es machen. Ich
habe mal eine andere Frage an euch. Hat mal einer zufälligerweise diesen Hersteller bei
USVs ausprobiert? Ich weiß, random, super random Themenwechsel hat mal einer das da ausprobiert.
Also nicht explizit die, sondern hat mal einer was von dem Hersteller gehabt? Weil, ich bin
immer noch am überlegen, ob ich mir nicht doch eine USV ins Rack haue. Ich habe eine,
taugt die. Und was ich viel interessanter finde, läuft die weiter, wenn die Batterie
abkackt. Also, noch mal so für alle, ich hab's letztens nicht mehr erzählt. Ich hatte
ja eine Cyber Power USV Rack. Ja, so ein Teil hier in der Richtung hatte ich so was da.
Sieht ziemlich genauso aus wie das. Alter, wir hatten das Bild, das ist ja mal. Igitt,
was ist mit eurem Background los? Also so ein Teil in der Richtung hatte ich. Und das Problem
damit war, was ist das für ein abfuck Hintergrund, man? Ist das von Chrome der neueste transparent
Background oder was? So, also da hatte ich welche. Und auf eines Morgens, ich hatte,
ich kanns euch ja mal zeigen, ich bin mir gar nicht sehr, wie heißt das Ding? Cyber Power
600. Ja, das wird's wahrscheinlich sein. Das sieht sehr genau aus, wie das, was ich
aktuell hab. Oder besser gesagt, auch im Rack hängen habe, aber nicht mehr verwende. So,
also das Problem, was ich damit hatte, ist, die hat immer wunderbar funktioniert. Überhaupt
gar kein Problem. Eines Tages war mein komplettes Rack aus. Und ich denk mir, warum? Stromausfall
oder was? Nö, Strom geht. Was passiert ist, der Akku war kaputt. Und da hat sich die USB
einfach gedacht, ja, wenn der Akku kaputt ist, dann bin ich auch kaputt. Dann geht gar
nix mehr. So, und ich kann mich ja noch dunkel dran erinnern, dass es verschiedene Typen
von USBs gibt. Also erst einmal so die klassische USB, die tatsächlich umschaltet, wenn, das
Strom, wenn Stromausfall ist. So, dann hast du Sachen, die das permanent durch die Batterie
leiten. Und dann hast du noch irgendwas drin, das weiß ich jetzt aber gerade vergessen habe.
So, und wahrscheinlich war das hier so eine, die das durch die Batterie leitet. Das ist
natürlich, hat seine Vorteile, ja, zum Beispiel, dass es keine Spannungsspitzen gibt oder sonst
was. Aber ganz im Ernst, ich hab keinen Bock, dass von fünf Jahren der einzige Ausfall
ist, nicht der Stromausfall, sondern das mein USB verreckt und der Akku wird früher oder
später verrecken. So, das heißt, ich will eine USB, ich will quasi die billigste USB
von der Bauart haben, ich will eine USB, die einfach geht und den Strom durchleitet, solang
Strom da ist. So, also ihr sagt, dass der Hersteller taugt was, ich weiß halt nicht,
ob das, was der USB hier auch so ist. Also im Zweifelsfall wäre cool, wenn man die auch
aufmachen könnte und den Akku wechseln, ohne dass man das ausschalten muss. Wobei ich mir
vorstellen könnte, dass das nicht so gebaut ist, du kommst da wahrscheinlich gar nicht
richtig dran. Ja, ich will ja auch keine 300 Euro USB. Ja, also meint ihr sowas? Ja, kannst
du bei dem Ding, kannst du dort die Batterie im laufenden Betrieb wechseln, geht das? Also
könntest du, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man die öffnet hier, keine Ahnung. Ich guck mal
kurz in das Handbuch. Manual. Die Sonnenkönig Eco. Äh, das glaube ich einfach nur schlecht
übersetzt, oder? So, wie tauscht man, wie tauscht man denn hier Batterien? Wie ich solche Bedienungsanleitungen
hasse, Alter. Das ist absoluter, absoluter Schmutz, wie man da so heute sagte. Ihr wisst,
Hello Fellow Kids, ich muss bisschen Jugendsprache trainieren, um am Puls der Zeit zu bleiben.
Ja, ich hab gehört, man so Schmutz sagt man da jetzt dazu. Nicht mehr Dreck, früher hat
man gesagt Dreck, mittlerweile sagt man Schmutz. Aber war Schmutz nicht vor drei Jahren? Ah,
kann sein, kann sein. Möglich. Sus. Bald mach ich das wie die Tagesschau-Sprecherin. Sus.
Die haben glaube ich, ich glaube diesen Tagesschau-Clip haben die hochgeladen, weil irgendjemand
dort erkannt hat, das hat Meme-Potenzial. Irgendeiner von den Nicht-Boomer-Mitarbeitern
dort bei der ARD hat das kapiert und hat das hochgeladen, hat Gold richtig damit gelegen.
Ist Digger, ist Digger wirklich immer noch angesagt? Digger war doch vor fünf Jahren
schon. Was ist es denn jetzt wieder? Brudi? Ne, immer noch Digger? Das sagt man immer
noch Digger? Also wir haben immer gesagt Alter, das sag ich ja immer noch. Alter. Digger
sagt man immer noch, jetzt ist es auch langsam schwierig. Wenn Bruder durch ist, Alter durch
ist Digger durch ist. Valar, ja Valar hat ja nichts mit Digger zu tun. Wobei das hat
auch abgenommen. Bratan ist richtig cringe. So, also wie tauscht man denn jetzt die Batterien?
Also aktuell seh ich da halt einfach nur Stecker, da wäre ich auf die Idee, da wäre ich auch
selbst noch gekommen. Beep, machts da wenn man da drauf drückt. Sehr schön. Das hätte
ich mir nicht gedacht. Aha, Battery Change. Kann man das im laufenden Blittrieb machen?
Take care not to inverse polarity. Wie wärs damit, wenn man die Stecker einfach unterschiedlich
macht, dass man nicht polarity reversen kann? Save nicht, kauf einfach alle vier Jahre
eine neue, da muss ich ja alle vier Jahre einmal ausschalten, um eine neue anzuschließen.
Auf der anderen Seite Patrick, ich glaube, das ist gar keine so blöde Idee. Weil ganz
im Ernst 84 Euro alle vier Jahre kann man sich eigentlich mal gönnen. Oder ich mach
so wie bisher und lass einfach das ganze Ding ohne USV laufen, weil seit meine letzte verreckt
ist hab ich auch nichts dran, es ist noch nie was passiert. Aber es ist noch nie was
passiert, Famous Last Words, ihr wisst ja. Am Endeffekt ist dann irgendwie das Raid
korrupt, wobei ich ja gar kein richtiges Raid im klassischen Sinn mehr hab.
Die sagen nicht explizit, dass man, ach doch, guck mal, man muss soll rausziehen. Die sagen,
man soll den Stecker raus machen, bevor man die Batterie wechselt. Ok, also man soll ausschalten.
Ok, Batterie charge, ne, change, change, change. Weil vielleicht, Chet, was mein dir? Soll
ich einfach YOLO Modus weiterfahren, scheiß drauf, ohne USV? Was würdet ihr machen? Also
man weiß halt nicht, was da auf einen zukommt. Es kann morgen der Stromausfall sein oder
halt auch nie. Meint ihr eine USV? Vom Preis erscheint die ja ok zu sein. Aber ich will
die mit USV, ich will die mit USV. Also die ist kacke, ich brauch die mit USV. Also bräuchte
ich mindestens die hier, 106 Euro. Weil ohne USV ist Müll. Ich muss den Status auslesen
können. Äh, ja was hat die jetzt eigentlich für Anschlüsse? Hat die so Kaltgerätestecker
oder hat die Schoko-Dosen? Dean im Namen lässt mich darauf schließen, dass die Schoko-Dosen
hat und keine Kaltgerätestecker. Kann die andere das nicht auch? Die hat, ne, das glaube
ich nicht. Ich glaube die Netzwerkstecke hier oben sind rein Überspannungsschutz. Glaub
nicht, dass da eh. Das ist ja wahnsinnig gut aufgelöstes Bild hier. Ne, das ist glaube
ich einfach ein Überspannungsschutz. Ich glaube nicht, dass die Netzwerk Connect hat.
Das wird mich bei dem Preis wirklich wundern. Also die haben ja eher USB-Verbindung bevor
sie Netzwerkverbindung haben. Also Anschlüsse erklären ist out, das braucht man nicht.
Guck mal, FR Dean hat Stecker? Ne, doch. Okay, das ist überhaupt nicht. Ich bin überhaupt
nicht dran, ich traine Network. Ne, Modern Ethernet can be protected in searches. Okay,
das hat kein, das hat keine Datenaustausch. Das ist nur, das ist rein Überspannungsschutz.
Joa. Also, zeig mal her. Ja, deswegen will ich auch ne billige. Ich will, dass es weiter
läuft, wenn die Batterie verreckt. Ich will nicht den Akku überbrücken. Ich will, dass
das Ding weiter läuft, solange Strom aus der Steckdose kommt, auch wenn der Akku im Zweifelsfall
rausgezogen ist. Das soll einfach funktionieren, solange Strom aus der Wand kommt. Es gibt
Videos. Okay, okay, Sekunde. Change Battery. Ja, das ist so ne super fette. Das sind ja,
das sind ja die Profi-Dinger. Da komm ich nicht weit mit. Wie heißen die normale? Ellipse?
Replace Battery. Okay, zeig her. Ja, super, da hat die nicht angeschlossen. Das ist jetzt
ja auch nichts, nichts, äh, nichts sagend. Das, das krieg ich, ja, das krieg ich schon
hin, die zu wechseln. Frage ist halt, wie sieht's aus, wenn die abgeschl... Also, wenn
die nicht angeschlossen ist. Die machen das alle ab? Machen das alle ab? Okay, how to
change battery? Switch OPS off from the front panel and unplug. Ah, das ist doch Dreck alles,
oder? Ich kauf mir keine USB, scheiß drauf. Lass es einfach, wie's ist. Und wenn's ausfällt,
fällt's aus. Gibt doch hier eh kaum Stromausfälle. Naja, um den Preis, was ich erwarte? Naja,
solange Strom aus der Leitung kommt, es weiterläuft. Das ist die billigste Art von USBs, weil die
nur umschalten, wenn wirklich der Strom ausfällt. Warum sollte der Strom ausgehen, wenn es überhaupt
nicht durch die Batterie läuft? Im RZ schaltet keiner seine USB aus beim Batteriewechsel.
Ah ja, du hast auch im Zweifelsfall zwei, aber das bei uns ein USB ausgeschaltet, um
die Batterie zu wechseln, hab ich noch nie mitgekriegt. Schmutzdigger, genau. Ich will
die Batterie nicht im laufenden Betrieb wechseln, auch wenn ich das die ganze Zeit sage. Mir
geht's da drum, dass wenn die Batterie den Geist aufgibt durch Altersschwäche, dass
es weiterläuft, solange Strom aus der Wand kommt. Ich hab keinen Bock, dass in drei Jahren
wird da mein Rack verreckt, nicht weil der Strom ausfällt, sondern weil die USB im Arsch
ist. Ey, es sind bei uns auch schon so viele bescheuerte Sachen passiert, weil Techniker
nicht aufgepasst haben. Das eine Video hab ich euch ja mal erzählt, mit dem USB Stick,
den sie in den Fahrstuhl geworfen haben, ausversehen durch den Schlitz. Naja, nee Leute, keine
USB. Was hab ich denn hier noch im Bars getrennt? Theoretisch müssen wir endlich mal, die hab
ich übrigens mittlerweile gekauft, die Wetterstation. Oh, Massive Ersparnis, Leute. Decreased von
69,96 auf 58,57. Und da sagt mal einer, es wird alles teurer. Das ist der Gegenbeweis
hier. Ja, dann ist gut, das wäre zum Beispiel was, warum ich hier wieder eine hinstellen
würde. Die dürfen ruhig maulen, wenn die Batterie kaputt ist, aber das Rack soll nicht
ausgehen. Hauptsache man kann sie muten. Hä? Ach so. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie ich das
geschafft hab. Taskbar Settings. So anscheinend. Nee, Colors. Custom. Anscheinend so, ich hab
keinen Plan. Ach so, hier unten hab ich das abgehakt irgendwie. Custom Color ist doch
nur. Ah nee, Window ist im Dark Mode, App ist im Light Mode. Alles klar. Was man da alles
für widersprüchliche Dinger machen muss, dass Windows das macht, was man haben will.
Es gibt Wasserkocher, auf die du das Motor flashen kannst. Echt? Zeig Link, wo? Das wäre
was für mich. Eton Flex. Nee, das ist keine USB, das ist einfach nur eine Stromleiste.
Das ist keine USB, oder? Ach doch. Welche davon? Die kleinste, hä? Welche davon? Die
sind mir so kryptisch benannt. Den hier zum Beispiel. Okay, okay. Ach so, Moment. Profi...
Nein. Profi Kuck. Hat nichts mit Jep Kuck zu tun. Profi Kuck. PC WKS 2-in-1 Tea-Water-Kettle.
Warum entsteht das bei mir eigentlich auf Deutsch? Und man kann allen Ernstes das Ding
flaschen. Da ist ein ESP 2866 drin. Das ist ja mal ein Pog, Alter. Das brauche ich. Ein
flashbarer Wasserkocher. Aber der hat nicht wirklich gute Bewertung, oder? Warum nicht?
Alles irgendwelche Fake-Reviews. Das Teil funkt ausschließlich im 4,5 GHz Netz. Ja, okay,
die Bewertungen sind wahrscheinlich schlecht, weil die App kacke ist. Und das umgehe ich
ja komplett, weil ich die App nicht verwende. Aber die Sache ist halt die Chat, ihr habt
recht. Du musst ja Wasser eh von Hand reinfüllen. Ich meine, du könntest abends Wasser reinfüllen
und morgens dann einschalten. Das wäre zum Beispiel nicht schlecht. Du könntest es
abends voll machen und morgens, wenn du dir Tee kochen willst, drückst, geht es dann
schon an, wenn deine Heimautomatisierung erkennt. So krass verkalkt das über Nacht auch nicht.
Zumal selbst wenn da irgendwas drin wäre und sich vermehrt über Nacht, wenn du es kochst,
ist es eh vorbei. Also, had to return. Warum? It turned on whilst being empty. Moment, das
hat kein Check dagegen, ob da nicht Wasser, ob es leer ist. Also jeder normale ordentliche
Wasserkocher hat ein Check drin, ob Wasser drin ist oder nicht. Aber wenn du es flaschen
kannst, ist es ein China-Chinesen-Gerät, oder? Hersteller? ProfiCookStore. Ok, das könnte
durchaus ein China-Chinesen Zeug sein vom Namen her. ProfiCook.de. Deutschlands Beste.
Das ist einfach nur re-branded oder so. Impressum. Ok, das ist anscheinend wirklich
eine deutsche Firma, aber vielleicht ist es re-branded. Auf der anderen Seite, wenn es
sogar bei Tasmota als ProfiCook drinne steht. So, die Frage ist, kann man den aktuell überhaupt
noch flaschen? Guck mal AliExpress, da muss ich aber nicht nach ProfiCook suchen, sondern
nach was soll ich denn suchen auf AliExpress? It's 2 in 1 Tea & Water Kettle. Wieder was
gelernt, weil ich wusste gar nicht, dass es Kettle heißt. Aber heute haben wir keine Hose
zu ficken. Also wenn ich dabei war und ich frage, was labert da, Max? Letztes Mal Vorschlag
bei AliExpress war, nach was ich suchen soll, Hose für Ficken. Autovervollständigung. Als
ich die Seite das erste Mal geladen habe. Genau, da gibts. Guck mal, es gibt sogar
eine Xiaomi-Mijia-Dinger, bestimmt Zigbee Übertragung. Also die Dinger sehen eindeutig
zu futuristisch aus, dass sie gescheit funktionieren. Ah ja, der ist bestimmt, also Leute, ich glaube,
den bestelle ich, den 5,99€ China-Chinesen Wasserkocher. Der ist bestimmt genau das
Richtige. Der hat bestimmt auch alle Prüfzeichen, die sind bestimmt auch alle echt. Es ist anscheinend
nicht Reprinted, ich sehe hier keinen. Moment. Der sieht dem doch, nee. Anderer. Das Motor.
Nee. Okay, und den kann man wirklich flashen, ja? Das muss ich jetzt gleich mal. Ich mein,
es spricht auch für, dass es kaum andere Geräte gibt, die exakt genauso aussehen.
Okay, das muss ich jetzt gleich mal checken. Erstmal muss ich die Musik wieder anmachen.
Ja, komm. Wo sind wir stehen geblieben hier? Das kann man jetzt wirklich flashen, oder?
Das muss ich jetzt mal in den Kommentaren gucken. Das Motor. Das Motor. Ah, November 2022. Ob
sich das eineinhalb Jahre jetzt noch flashen lässt? Flash. Schwer zu sagen. Vielleicht
lässt sich das auch nicht mehr flashen. Hm. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das auf gut Glück
kaufen soll, Leute. Eigentlich ist es zu teuer für so was Unsinniges. 60€. Aber wenn das
Ding, Leute, das muss ein China-Chinesen-Produkt sein. Okay, China. Heißt das wirklich Waterkette?
Wi-Fi. AliExpress. Das muss ein Reprint sein. Wenn es kein Reprint ist, dann wäre das doch
kein Tuya Zeug. Dann hätten die ein ordentliches Webinterface gemacht oder so. Da stand Warning
wegen Wi-Fi. Was? Ja, das steht bei allen Tuya Sachen. Ich weiß, ich weiß. Aber vielleicht
ist es ja tatsächlich in dem Fall auch so. Das sieht erst mal relativ ähnlich. Hier,
da ist er. Das ist er doch, oder? Das sieht sehr ähnlich aus, das Ding. Die Basis ist
ein bisschen anders. Die Basis ist ein bisschen anders. Aber guck mal. Mobile. Hä? Das sieht
da wieder komplett anders aus. Aber das da hinten? Wieso willst du das Ding flashen?
Naja, weil ich alles flashe, was flashbar ist. Nee, das sieht tatsächlich anders aus.
Der Profi Kok. Der Griff ist auch ganz anders. Ja, da finde ich das passende China-Chinesen-Produkt
nicht. Ich verstehe den Sinn auch nicht. Deswegen werde ich es mir wahrscheinlich nicht kaufen.
Der Sinn erschließt sich mir nämlich wirklich nicht. Das Einzige, was mir einfällt, ist,
man könnte abends Wasser reinmachen und es dann morgen kochen lassen, wenn man ins Bad
geht oder so. Aber naja. Das könnte man auch anders mit einer Wi-Fi-schaltbaren Steckdose
könnte man das genauso machen. Ich glaube, ich werde das nicht kaufen. Okay, welche davon
sollte ich mir denn jetzt angucken, dass ich weiß, wie das preislich liegt? Doch, ich
brauche einen Wasserkocher. Ich wollte mir eigentlich den Wasserkocher hier holen, weil
ich habe quasi den davor und der hat jetzt irgendwie 13 Jahre gehalten oder so. Nee,
11. Nee, 9. 2013 habe ich den gekauft. Temperatur einstellen wäre auch sinnvoll. Na gut, das
heißt Wasserkocher, weil man da mit Wasser kocht. Und Wasser kochen geht halt nur mit,
also was brauchst du da Temperatur? Aber ja, das andere wäre ein Wasserkocher-Schrägstrich-Erwärmer,
dann wäre das mit Temperatur sinnvoll. Mit dem Switchpot den Wasserhahn. Genau, ein Schlauch
am Wasserhahn und dann mit dem Switchpot den Wasserhahn schalten. Exzellent. Das machen
wir in der Chain-Lore. Kann ich das anklicken? Ich wusste mir das gerade mal. Bin ich mir
bei dir immer nicht so sicher. Ich gucke mal auf dem zweiten Bildschirm, ob man sich
das anschauen kann. Ah ja, okay, das ist safe. PokiW-Virgin-Check, I'm safe. Manchmal kommen
mir unsinnigerweise solche dämlichen Copypasta in den Kopf. Ich weiß nicht warum. Ich habe
heute auf der Arbeit Fivehead gesagt. Einfach so, Fivehead. Also sowas macht ihr in der
11. Klasse. Ist das ein Bild von euch aus dem Klassenraum? Nee, oder? Das ist bei dir
aus dem Zimmer. Wobei, nee, das ist aus dem Klassenraum. Da ist ein Arm von irgendeinem
anderen Dude. Okay, sowas macht ihr da mit dem guten allen Strukturizer 3.28-10 Krankenhaus.
Krankenhaus? Und neben dran den Windows-Taschenrechner. Ich weiß ja nicht, ich weiß ja nicht was
ich schlimmer finde. Die Kombination aus Oldest School, Anwendung plus UWP oder dass es Strukturgramme
sind. Aber du hast deine Leiste und so schon mal im Dark Mode, das ist schon mal gut. By
the way, Chain-Lore. Wie alt ist denn euer Windows? Weil das ist der Calculator vom vorletzten
Feature-Update. Der aktuelle Calculator sieht so aus, auch in der Taskleiste. Das ist bestimmt
noch LTS oder so von vor drei Jahren. Die machen kein Update. Genauso sieht das auch
aus. Das wundert mich nicht. Hast du eine Smartwatch? Hab ich nicht. Kannst du dich aussprechen.
Smartwatch. Okay, was macht ihr denn da, schönes Chain-Lore? Zeigt mal hier. Krankenhaus.
Aufenthaltsdauer, Versicherungsart, Pflegeart. Okay, okay, ich geh mal in mich. Strukturgramm.
Das hier sind so die Parameter, die man übergibt. In dem Fall halt. Okay, Kommandozeilen, Eingabe.
Grundbetrag gleich 200 Euro. Versicherungsart, TF. Wie? Was ist T und F? Gesetzlich oder
privat oder? Ne. Ach, True, False. Wie kann eine Versicherungsart True oder False sein?
Wie? Hä? Okay, hat eine Versicherung oder hat keine, hat keine Versich... Okay, versichert.
Versichert sollte das eigentlich bedeuten. Versichert, Fragezeichen. Ja, nein. Zuschlag.
Warum muss man, warum muss man unversichert mehr bezahlen? Den Zuschlag gibt es doch
sonst auch, oder? Oder na gut, das sind quasi Selbstzahler. Selbstzahler, wenn immer krasser
zur Kasse gebeten, ja. Wobei das, wobei das so ohne weiteres gar nicht zulässig ist,
du musst das, du musst das nach, äh, Dings hier Ärzte Gebührenordnung abrechnen und
einfach random Zuschläge verteilen, bin ich mir nicht so sicher. Egal, das ist ja nur
eine Aufgabe, das hat ja mit der Realität nichts zu tun. Also, ähm, Unterbringung,
Verpflegungsart True, False. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass Verpflegungsart auch True oder
False sein kann. Dieses Struktogramm ist einfach mal so krass useless. Warum macht man sowas?
Kein Plan soll fast lernen, ja. Was auch immer, man da ist großartig lernt bei. Okay, okay,
wie sie? Fy-FyFat. Oh, ich muss ja merken, wo ich war. Okay, wie sie? Erklär mir als
super FyFat Entwickler, wie kann Verpflegungsart True oder False sein? Das will ich jetzt
wissen. Was ist ein Verpflegungsart True oder False? Wenn du nur ein, ich hab keine Ahnung.
False gleich verhungern. Ist das, ist das du bekommst Essen oder nicht? Dann, dann muss
man das doch einfach nur Verpflegung Fragezeichen nennt, nicht Verpflegungsart. Aber das ist
komplett useless, dieses Diagramm. Was soll einem das jetzt bringen? Also ich mein, anhand
dessen könntest du immer noch nichts programmieren, weil du nicht mal weißt, wie du Eingabe machst.
Aber gut, was auch immer, ich finde es bedenklich, dass ihr Struktogramme macht. Sogar der,
hast du 15 von 15 bekommen, dann ist ja pock, dann ist ja alles gut. Sogar der Struktogramm-Erfinder
hat ein paar Jahre später gesagt, dass Struktogramme nicht so der Weisheit letzter Schluss sind.
Wenn es der Struktogramm-Erfinder sagt. Oje, schreib das mal nicht auf Twitter. Wenn du
das auf Twitter schreibst, dann ist es richtig, dann ist es regert. Canceled. Früher, vor
noch nicht allzu langer Zeit hättest du wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Konstanten so definieren können.
Aber heutzutage würde ich das lieber sein lassen. Egal, gut, dass du 15 Punkte bekommen
hast, Chainlord, pock. Was passiert eigentlich, wenn man da auf Debug klickt? Geht da dann
die einzelnen Punkte durch oder so? Ich hab den Strukturizer schon 15 Jahre oder so nicht
mehr verwendet. Ich kenn mich da nicht mehr so aus. Der Strukturizer, so ein Blödsinn.
Aber der Taschenrechner ist am Start. Na gut, ich mein, kann man ja auch nicht erwarten,
dass man das im Kopf rechnen kann. Das ist eindeutig zu schwer. 200 plus 100 plus 100
und dann vielleicht noch plus 7. Ok, mal auf den Hals Dauer wird es tatsächlich dann
schon ein bisschen schwieriger. Ok, das verstehe ich, das verstehe ich. Ja, alles klar. Also
wenn man das ganze mal 37 rechnen soll oder so, dann ja. Wirklich? Ich Strukturizer, ist
das Java? Ich mein, das sieht so hässlich aus. Das könnte tatsächlich Java sein. Wahrscheinlich
irgendwie, das ist doch nicht mal Swing. Was gab es denn vor Swing? Noch älter. Strukturizer,
GitHub. AWT, stimmt. Strukturizer. Fischl, der ist es. Da gibt es gar keinen Sourcecode
dazu. Der Strukturizer ist nicht Open Source, Anzeige. Wobei man kann keinen Anzeigen dafür,
dass er nicht Open Source ist. Das wäre doch mal was, oder? Einfach gleich verklagen, wer
nicht Open Source ist. Opening when complete. Ja, auf. Komm, es ist complete. Source? Trau
ich es, mich aufzumachen. Wo ist mein VS Code? Hallo? Wozu? Wo ist es hin? Da ist es doch.
Kann man das Track und Dropen? Nee, oder? Nee. Okay, okay. Trick 17. Notepad öffnen,
neues File machen, einfügen und dann umstellen auf Java. Alter, was ein Ding. Wird immer noch
regelmäßig updated. Okay Leute, erkennt man Java Experten? Erkennt man, was das für
eine GUI Library ist, irgendwo ran? Main, der muss ja irgendwo das Fenster starten jetzt.
Command Line Arguments. Der passt ganz viele. Sag mal, da gibt es noch einen Command Line
Parser, oder? What the fuck? UI Manager, set look and feel. UI Manager, get. Okay, das
ist, das ist. Können wir gucken, was das Java ist. UI Manager. Swing, Swing ist es. Alles
klar, okay. Und ganz schnell, ganz schnell wieder weg. No. Nicht, nicht saven. Gut, wissen
wir Bescheid. Swing. Aber eins muss man mal sagen, ich meine, der Kram funktioniert.
Man kann sich da jetzt noch so viel drüber lustig machen, ja. Der hat was entwickelt,
was wahrscheinlich schon mehr Leuten geholfen hat, als viele andere. So gut wie jeder in
der Berufsschule oder jeder Informatiker oder Fachinformatiker oder sei es nur IT Klasse
in der Schule benutzt irgendwann mal den Strukturizer. Wo kommt das neue Pepega Board? Wurde die
Entwicklung getroppt? Naja, das tun für mich das Pepega Board. Für alle anderen muss
das nicht tun, zumal das Pepega Board einige Ungereimtheiten hat. Man könnte auch sagen,
Bugs, die es manchmal crashen lassen, wenn ich neue Bilder hinzufüge und es nicht in
der richtigen Reihenfolge anklicke. Kannst du Weird Champing abspielen? Ja. Ups. Ja.
Weird Champing. Und hinterher eine Runde Gachirole. So, gut. Wir haben Strukturkram tatsächlich
teilweise noch von Hand gezeichnet. Und das war in der Berufsschule 2007 oder so herum.
Also das ist doch gar nicht so lange her. Nicht so, dass es letztes Jahr 1000 war. 2007
ist jetzt auch schon ein bisschen her, aber es ist wie gesagt nicht letztes Jahr 1000
oder 1990 oder so. Von Handzeichen ist wahrscheinlich einfacher. Ich glaube die Software ist gar
nicht so kacke. Für das, was es sein soll, ist doch gut. Weil da hat sich hingesetzt
einfach Sinnvolles entwickelt. Passt doch. Ja, ich hab mal eine neue, ich hab mit FFm
verpackt und der Renderer könnte tatsächlich DirectX gewesen sein, die Bilder ins Fenster
rendern. Ja, das hab ich mal angefangen, dass solche Bilder wie das hier, guck, weil
WPF ist richtig lahm. WPF ist richtig lahm bei sowas hier, guck. Bei manchen GIFs, die
etwas bessere Auflösung haben und mehr FPS. Ich hab jetzt schon längst geklickt und es
kommt immer noch nichts. Guck, das ist richtig, richtig lahm. Und das hab ich gerendert mit
FFm pack und das war instant da. FFm pack ist richtig massive Pog. Ja, FFm pack ist
das beste oder eines der besten. Übrigens, Chat, wo wir gerade dabei sind. Ganz kurz,
zwei Minuten. Ich weiß, dass nicht alle dabei waren. Ich habe rausbekommen, woran das mit
dem Filename lag. Erinnert ihr euch noch dran, dass wir gestern versucht haben, was zu programmieren?
Wo ich auf meine Router-API zugreifen wollte. Ich habe rausbekommen, woran es lag. Passt
mal auf. Wie gesagt, zwei Minuten. Wenn ich dabei war, wird es jetzt nicht checken. Ich
zeige euch, woran es gelegen hat. Die eine Stelle, woran es gelegen hat, zeige ich euch.
So, auf, geh an. Und zwar, es war die Reihenfolge. Es muss sein, Name gleich u und die.NET Library
hat geschrieben, Filename gleich. Und danach, also das hier und das hier war vertauscht.
Ihr habt es glaube ich gesehen. Die Reihenfolge ist das Problem gewesen. Korrekt. Also sprich,
das hier und das hier muss vertauscht werden. Wobei das vertauscht in der Klasse nicht getan
hat logischerweise. Ich musste wirklich das von Hand String interpolate die Message. Dann
hat es funktioniert. Habe ich ausprobiert. Also die Reihenfolge ist entscheidend. Ich
gehe davon aus, dass das nicht standardkonform ist. Ne, ich mache jetzt mal mein Tool fertig.
Also ich will zumindest über Kommandozeile WLANs auflisten können, User auflisten können
und neue User anlegen. Dann verwende ich den, ja. Aber das ist garantiert nicht standardkonform,
weil ich, also ich habe ihn nicht gelesen, aber ich gehe ganz stark davon aus, im Standard
steht die Reihenfolge, der Felder ist egal, weil die Library generiert nicht ohne Grund
das so. Ich meine, das ist der offizielle unter der Haube, der offizielle HTTP-Klein
von.NET. Dass der nicht standardkonforme Formrequest macht, glaube ich nicht. Ich
muss jetzt mal, ich mache jetzt mal wieder Chat, ja. Du schreibst hier Nutzerartstilung
Spider-Man mit Gnome. Jetzt müsste ich dich fragen, warum nicht Manjaro? Warum nicht
Endeavor OS? Das ist immer so die Standardfrage vom Chat. Ich sage irgendwas, so nach dem
Motto, ja wir gucken uns das jetzt mal an, da kommt der Chat um die Ecke. Ja, warum nicht
mit was anderem? Warum nicht so? Warum machst du es so? Warum nicht anders? Ich muss das
auch mal machen öfters. Warum nicht Windows? Die Antwort ist ganz einfach, Windows ist
immer Painschamp, egal was du machst. Gibt es irgendwas, was unter Windows nicht Painschamp
ist? Ich meine, du kannst unter Windows spielen, ja. Das ist aber auch Painschamp. Das einzige,
warum das die Leute machen ist, weil es die einzige Plattform ist, wo du wirklich sicher
sein kannst, dass alle Games laufen. Also Konsole außen vor, aber da geht es ja nicht
rum. Windows halt. Windows ist immer Painschamp. Selbst Windows unter Windows ist schwierig.
Windows, es ist alles schwierig unter Windows. Wo bin ich denn stehen geblieben, Freund?
Ich habe bestimmt noch irgendwas übersehen, warte mal. Easy Ausbildung. Ich habe nichts
übersehen, oder? Nix. Na ja gut, mal einmal refreshen, vielleicht hat YouTube noch ein
schönes Video, was wir uns jetzt heute zum Einschlafen angucken können. Introducing
Avandos Pro. Nein, ich weiß nicht, was es ist. Ich will es wahrscheinlich auch nicht
wissen. Keine Ahnung, will man nicht, will man nicht haben. Kennst du den Java Editor?
Also wenn ich einen Java Editor suche, finde ich wahrscheinlich 1000 Sachen, oder? Ach
Moment, das heißt wirklich so. Ach du Scheiße, das ist noch aktuell. Hallo? Guck mal, die
Seite ist sogar down, Leute, die Seite geht nicht mal auf. Ach du Scheiße. Ach du Kruse.
Das ist ja Monka Shake, Alter. Das wollte ich gar nicht drücken. Das sieht aus wie
Software, die man in der Berufsschule verwendet, ja. Man verwendet das in der Berufsschule,
weil die Berufsschule vor 30 Jahren mal Lizenzen dafür gekauft hat. Na gut, nicht so feifett.
Ach ja, was macht New World? Abkacken, was macht Battlefield? Noch mehr abkacken, Alter.
Easy, bald Race to Null Players ist eröffnet. So schlecht. Ja, das kenne ich auch noch,
das Ding. Es hat mich immer noch irritiert, das ernsthaft, was Bloodshed heißt. Kann
die denn Modern C++, um die Sache noch schlimmer zu machen? Modern C++, die Sprache, die zum
größten Teil aus Klammern in dieser Richtung hier besteht. Wahrscheinlich ist das, Leute,
meint ihr, das ist Welle C++ Syntax? Ich gehe davon aus. Ich denke, das geht. Und im Zweifelsfall,
wenn es nicht geht, ist die Fehlermeldung 40 Zeilen lang und man versteht nicht, was
die Fehlermeldung einem sagen soll. Testen wir doch mal. Es gibt doch so einen Online
C++ Compiler. Ist das da? Nee, das meine ich nicht. Ist das gültiges C++ Run? Moment.
Ist das wirklich halbwegs hilfreiche Compiler-Fehlermeldung? Sehe ich das gerade richtig? Ich meine, dass
er das 580 mal schreibt, ist vielleicht nicht so sinnvoll, aber das kann nicht sein. Das
ist Fake C++. Ist die Scharpe in Whistle Studio oder in Whistle Studio oder Codebesser zu
programmieren? Eindeutig. Eindeutig in Whistle Studio. Oder aber gar nichts davon und Ryder.
Ryder ist mein persönlicher Favorit, aber Ryder ist halt offiziell nicht kostenlos,
es sei denn, du bist Student oder Schüler und du hast die Trial ausgenutzt. 30 Tage
kannst du es kostenlos verwenden. Na sehr teuer ist es nicht. Ich finde Ryder ist tatsächlich
relativ angemessen. Also ich habe das JetBrains All Products Pack. Ich will alles. Ja. Und
das kostet für Privatpersonen nicht so viel wie da steht. Für persönliche Nutzung. Guck
mal. All Products Pack 250 Euro im Jahr und ab dem dritten Jahr, das müsste ich mittlerweile
eigentlich schon haben, kostet es dann quasi irgendwie nur noch 100, 170 oder so. Das kann
man schon machen. Ich finde das ist gar nicht so teuer. Also wenn man das regelmäßig benutzt.
Ich mein, wenn man Schüler ist, würde ich es nicht unbedingt machen, aber wenn man das
unter anderem dafür benutzt, womit man dann sein Geld verdient, ist das eigentlich gar
keine Frage. Also vollkommen in Ordnung. Oder ihr lasst es euren Chef für euch kaufen.
Ritual Studio ist vollkommen in Ordnung. Ja, kann man auch benutzen. Ich habe auch jahrelang
Ritual Studio verwendet, aber seit ich seit.net Core im Endeffekt seit.net Core halbwegs sinnvoll
Cross Plattform ist, also seit 2.1 oder so oder 2.0 und auch alle notwendigen Klassen
hatte, ich glaube, es war so seit 2.0 2.1, bin ich ja komplett auf Linux als Entwicklungsplattform
umgestiegen und seitdem verwende ich nur noch Rider und ich komme damit echt gut klar.
Also ich kann das eigentlich nur empfehlen. Natürlich, wenn man das hobbymäßig verwendet
und Schüler ist und kein Geld hat, dann nicht, dann Ritual Studio. Aber Ritual Studio Code
würde ich nicht verwenden für C Sharp, weil das ist in Ritual Studio deutlich angenehmer.
Ja, doch Pog. Mache ich nicht. Deswegen habe ich mir mal Infinity Designer und Infinity
Photo gekauft, weil ich keinen Bock auf Adobe Gremble habe und ich Adobe Gremble erstens
nicht gescheit benennen kann und das zweitens viel zu teuer ist. Ja, also Visual Studio
Code für C Sharp ist nicht schön. Das habe ich auch schon mal Just For Fun ausprobiert,
aber das macht keinen Spaß. Webstorm habe ich nie, bin ich nie so richtig warm geworden
mit. Ich verwende tatsächlich für Frontend ausschließlich Visual Studio Code. Da gehen
ja auch die Meinungen auseinander. Ob Webstorm jetzt oder Visual Studio Code. Gibt Leute,
die schwören komplett auf Visual Studio Code und Leute, die schwören komplett auf Webstorm.
Werden wir hier nicht weiter behandeln. Profis programmieren in Vim. Ja, Leute, die in Vim
programmieren, die müssen vor allem, die erzählen, dass sie in Vim programmieren.
Das ist so ein bisschen wie Arch Linux User, die müssen das auch erzählen. Das sind die
gleichen Leute, die ja sagen, es ist alles so ineffizient. Meine Finger müssen auf der
Home Row Stain. Also wenn ich weiß, was die Home Row ist, Keyboard Layout, die Home Row
ist das Ding hier. In der Mitte. Das da. Das ist die Home Row. So. Und wenn deine Finger
nicht auf der Home Row Stain, dann ist es schlecht. Sagen die Vim Power User. Das Problem
ist nur in der heutigen Zeit, dass ich das für totalen Schwachsinn halte, weil was bringt
dir auf der Home Row zu Stain, wenn du die Maus brauchst, um den Browser ordentlich
zu bedienen und im Internet was nachzugucken. Und es ist einfach so, dass du auch wenn du
dich gut auskennst, 40 Prozent der Zeit trotzdem im Internet nachguckst und Dinger, Dinger
schaust und ausprobierst und nachgucken muss. Und sei es nur, dass du Tickets bearbeiten
musst, nebenbei mal kurz. Also das bringt dir überhaupt nichts, nur auf der Home Row
zu Stain. Ja, ich kenne das. Ich habe das selbst benutzt. Leute, ich habe das früher
selbst so gemacht. Ich hatte früher eine Vim-Config von 8000 Zeilen oder so mit 15 Extensions
und mein Vim hat immer nicht richtig funktioniert, nachdem ich die mal geupdatet habe. Ich habe
das früher genauso gemacht. Total abfuck. Heute habe ich die Vim-Config, die hat die
notwendigsten Sachen und fertig und ich verwende das nur, wenn ich schnell auf der Kommandozeile
was editieren muss und weil es auf jedem Server voll installiert ist. Genau, ich mache alles
nur noch über Sprachassistenten, dass ich auf der Home Row Stain kann. Also ich finde,
das ist heutzutage nicht zeitgemäß. Du verbringst bestimmt, ich sage jetzt mal 50 Prozent,
aber das schwankt ja bei manchen 30, bei manchen vielleicht 60, 70 Prozent des Tages im Browser
und du kannst einen Browser nicht gescheit bedienen über Tastatur-Shortcuts. Ich kenne
diese Plugins, ich habe die früher selbst verwendet, dass du den Browser mit Vim-Shortcuts
bedienen kannst. Das geht. Dann drückst du zum Beispiel F und der highlightet dir alle
Links und dann drückst du zum Beispiel ein BV oder so für den Link und das geht. Es
fühlt sich aber nicht nach natürlicher Browsernutzung an. Ganz ehrlich, Maus ist im Browser das
beste und da bringt es dir auch nichts, dass du im Vim geil auf der Home Row stayst und
dann alle zwei Sekunden trotzdem zur Maus rübergreifen musst. Ja, jeder was er will,
du kannst deinen Browser auch mit einem Gaspedal bedienen, wenn du denkst, dass du dann besser
auf der Home Row stayen kannst. Kein Problem, mach. V-Controller, das ist auch nice. Also
ich programmiere mit einem Lenkrad oft öfters mal. Also ich habe CS mit dem Lenkrad gespielt
früher und nachdem das hier noch rumliegt, programmiere ich da auch ganz gerne mal mit.
Maus auf dem Boden und am Schreibtisch. Jetzt weiß ich, man macht die Maus auf dem Boden,
stayt schön auf der Home Row mit seinen Fingern und man macht dann quasi so einen Klettverschluss
an die Maus dran und klettet sich die Maus quasi an den Fuß und dann kann man auf der
Home Row stayen und kann mit dem Fuß die Maus bewegen. Leute, das ist so eine bescheuerte
Idee. Ich könnte wetten, dass es Leute gibt, die machen das. Nicht viele, nicht viele,
aber es gibt bestimmt Leute, die machen das bzw. haben es zumindest probiert. Man spricht
ja erstmal nichts dagegen. Die Füße brauchst du zum Programmieren, nicht? Und wenn du
ein krasser, krasser auf der Home Row stayer bist, dann kannst du schon mal die Maus auch
mit der Tastatur, mit dem Fuß bedienen. Das Patent, das kannst du machreich ein. Tanzmatte.
Was ist das? Stream das lieber. TriHack streamt das auch manchmal, der Dance da auf so einem
komischen, was ist das, ein komischen Dance Game mit Tanzmatte. Was ein Azubi hat mir
erzählt, dass eine Firma BWL Stonks als Einstellungstest Excel Aufgaben stellt, Bedingung nur Tastatur
und keine Maus. Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, was ich daran absurder finden soll, dass man
glaubt, dass das Aussagekraft hat für einen IT-Job oder dass es irgendwie erstrebenswert
ist Excel nur mit Tastatur zu bedienen. Keine Ahnung, die Interviews und Einstellungstests
nehmen groteske Formen an mittlerweile. Ne, ich schnall mir meine Maus garantiert nicht
an Fuß. Dafür bin ich kein groß genuger auf der Home Row stayer. Ja, das ist wohl wahr.
Am besten ist es gar nicht zu benutzen. Trackpad für die Füße ist auch nicht schlecht. Da
kannst du immer so mit dem großen Fuß zäh, kannst du dann quasi über das Trackpad scratchen
oder noch besser auf dem Boden diesen komischen Joystick, den die Thinkpads immer haben. Bist
dir mal in den Trackpoint, den roten. Sowas kannst du bestimmt mit dem großen Fuß zäh
unterm Tisch gut bedienen für die Maus und dann kannst du immer auf der Home Row stayen
für maximale Wim-Shortcuts. Wie man Farben für eine Webseite auswählt. Ja, ich auch.
Easy Step. Ganz ehrlich, den besten Tipp, wisst ihr was den besten Tipp ist, den ich
je in einem Video gehört hab, wo es um Design ging, also den ich persönlich sehr sehr gut
und praktisch fand. Anfangen mit schwarz und weiß. Wenn die Seite schon in schwarz und
weiß ultra beschissen aussieht, dann soll man sich was anderes überlegen. Und erst
wenn die Seite in schwarz und weiß ganz, ganz brauchbar aussieht, dann noch die ein oder
anderen Farben dabei machen. Es muss nicht wirklich schwarz und weiß sein, es kann auch
grau und weiß sein. Aber erstmal die Webseite zweifarbig machen. Und wenn die Webseite da
schon mega beschissen aussieht, so dass man sie nicht benutzen möchte, dann ist was grundlegend
verkehrt. Und dann kann man sich ein paar Abstufungen überlegen, noch so zwei, drei
Farben dabei machen. Das fand ich war ein guter Ratschlag. Die Fußmause, wenn sowas
gibt es wirklich. Das ist ja fast so toll wie der Fanatic Headshot Controller. Ok 2008.
Das kann doch nicht wirklich irgendjemand verwendet haben, oder? Keine Ahnung, was sich alles
gibt. Ja, dafür ist tatsächlich, ich sag ja auch, ich hab das schon total auf dem Stream
gesagt, dass Excel, das meiner Meinung nach einzige Produkt ist, in der gesamten Office
Suite, was irgendwie eine Daseinsberechtigung hat. Ja auch, auch sagen wir mal auch für
mich vielleicht. Ich benutze zwar Excel nahezu nie, aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, das vielleicht
zu verwenden. Aber alles andere ist Müll. Outlook ist nicht Bestandteil von der Office
Suite. Im Office Suite ist Word, Excel, PowerPoint, früher war es noch Access. Und was hab ich
noch? Was hab ich noch vergessen? Publisher gab es früher, das war aber auch nur Bonus.
Ja, also Word, Excel, PowerPoint, Outlook ist standardmäßig nicht dabei. Access, Publisher,
ich glaub Standardmäßig auch nicht mehr. Ok, das war's. Also Word, Excel, PowerPoint,
Access. Also Access ist Paints Chairman. So und Word ist so ziemlich das Unsinnigste überhaupt.
Also wer Word verwendet hat glaube ich echt die Kontrolle über sein Leben verloren, weil
da wirklich abhängig von ist. Und nichts anderes als Alternative kennt, das ist schon sehr
sehr Paints Champion. Weil ich bin der Meinung, wenn man einfach nur Text schreiben will, dann
brauchst du keine Textverarbeitung, weil dann geht es ja um den Text. Und wenn man Text,
wenn man was optisch schön machen will, ja die Hardcore Leute machen das mit Latex, Latech,
wie man das genau ausspricht. Man kann das aber auch in jedem x-beliebigen Designerprogramm
machen, wenn es einfach nur hübsch aussehen soll. Ich mein niemand schreibt ein Buch
in Word, schickt es dem Verlag und der Verlag, der haut es dann in die Presse so nach dem
Motto. Vom Word Dokument zum Druck, das passiert ja nicht. Also deswegen, Word ist da halt
total unsinnig. Powerpoint, verwende ich tatsächlich am meisten davon, aber nur weil ich manchmal
muss, weil es bei uns auf der Arbeit immer noch Leute gibt, die der Meinung sind, man
muss die Corporate Identity Vorlagen verwenden, nur dann geht es als Präsentation durch.
Das Chebat Video, natürlich ist das Chebat, auch Comic Sans, was sonst, hab ich schon im
ersten April hochgeladen. Man kann einfach Fußnoten machen. Ja ok, ich lass mir's gefallen,
ich will ja keinem ausreden, dass er Word verwendet. Wenn jemand mit Word zufrieden ist
und das quasi Funktionen hat, die er braucht, das war meinetwegen, verwendet Word, ich will
euch ja nicht bekehren, macht was ihr wollt. Undok ist auch Pog, ja. Twitch Mason, danke
für den Sub. Leute, ich hab gefühlt wieder einige Subs übersehen, ich guck mal kurz
rein bevor ich gleich ins Bett gehen muss. Wolle hat gecheert mit Bits, Dankeschön
für die 250 Milliarden Bits. Joho hat abonniert, der Weezy hat abonniert, das hab ich alle
schon gesehen glaub ich, Doomsweb hat abonniert, Kengin, ja das hab ich schon gesehen, danke
Leute nochmal für die Subs, falls ich irgendwann übersehen hab, aber ich glaube nicht. Der
Name sagt mir was, ist es der mit dem Goldfisch, ist es der mit dem Goldfisch der angeblich
Stonks kauft, ja haben wir geguckt, das war auch reichlich sinnlos, ich mein im Prinzip
war das Randomize und der Goldfisch hatte damit, ja weiß nicht, nicht viel zu tun eigentlich,
das hätte ohne den Goldfisch fast genauso gut funktioniert. Trustfire, Dankeschön
für den Sub. Kommt auf die Firma an, kommt drauf an was du machst, kommt drauf an in
welcher Region du bist, kann man schlecht sagen, guck dir mal irgendwelche Vergleiche
an, gibt es ja genug Umfrage, ab und zu macht Heise ja auch so einen Gehaltsvergleich, aber
ansonsten schwierig zu sagen, ja, das stimmt wohl, ja, gleich Bett gehen, ja ich geh jetzt
mal. Ok Leute, ne wir gucken jetzt kein Axel Video, ist es der der Raytracing in Axel gemacht
hat? Ne. Es gab ja einen Raytracer für Axel irgendwie, kann ich mich erinnern. Ich mach
jetzt gar nichts, ich mach jetzt Heck Bett gehen, ich geh jetzt pennen, weil ich bin
übelst kaputt und morgen zum Glück wieder Homeoffice und das heißt ich bin danach auch
fitter, danach muss ich meine 1-2 Stunden Sport machen, gut Sport ihr wisst was ich
mach, ich laufe ein bisschen draußen rum, ich laufe etwas schneller 2 Stunden draußen
rum, 1,5-2 Stunden, nicht jeder würde Sport nennen, aber es hat was gebracht, ihr habt
als letztes auf der Waage gesehen, Meilenstein ist erreicht. Ja, jeden Tag 1-2 Stunden, das
sind nicht immer 2 Stunden, das ist meistens 1,5-2 Stunden, wo ich etwas schneller spazieren
gehe, nicht super krass schnell, also jetzt nicht hier irgendwie norwegisches Militärmarsch,
den Berg rauf, 7 Stunden Kilometer mit 35 Kilo Gepäck. Ach früher, ich hab hast du
früher, also ich glaube Wanderurlaub haben wir früher nie gemacht, kann ich mich nicht
daran erinnern, dass wir früher Wanderurlaub gemacht haben. An Strand sind wir öfters
ausgefahren, wo waren wir denn überall, die üblichen Sachen, Gran Canaria, Tenerife,
in der Türkei waren wir auch, kann ich mich noch dran erinnern, sowas, wobei ich in die
Türkei heute wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr fahren würde, die sind mir zu weird champ
geworden dort, nach Ägypten kannst du auch nicht mehr fahren, das sind auch weird champ
geworden, aber ganz im Ernst, ganz im Ernst, ja ich zähl Schritte, ich hab ja immer mein
iPhone dabei, das macht das ja so, in der Hells App standardmäßig schon, aber da guck
ich so gut wie nie rein, aber ich hab theoretisch einen Zähler, ja. Jetzt in Bitcoin investieren,
nee, ich hab ziemlich langweilige ETF Stonks, die dank den China-Chinesen ordentlich runtergegangen
sind die letzten paar Wochen. Wer ist die Katz? Chico. Chico, aber es ist ein Mädchen, warum
auch immer sie Chico heißt, ich weiß es nicht, die hieß schon so, die hab ich aus dem Tierheim
gehört, und warum soll ich die Oma nennen? Warum man die Katze Chico genannt hat, ich
habe keine Ahnung. Katzcam, keine Ahnung, ich geh jetzt bett hier, Leute wir sehen uns,
machts gut, bis morgen, vielleicht CU.